[Music]
samo versus donnie this is for real this
is not fast forward dude yeah ground
fighting again triangle choke this is
why this was the most fun i've ever had
on this set
we're back here with a stuntman react
joined by agita silva now gee is
actually a working stunt man in
hollywood he's done a lot of fight
scenes things from black panther captain
america civil war also some really
interesting motion capture stuff he's
leonardo from michael bay's ninja
turtles yep i've gotten to play master
chief for a brief second i've gotten to
be batman for another brief second this
is my childhood that's awesome man you
followed your passions and your dreams
as a kid and it led you to this point on
this couch with these two dudes right
now with these two awesome dudes yeah
you gotta put the adjective in front
we're about to have a great time then oh
yeah
yeah i'm excited i hope i don't curse
too much
[Laughter]
guardians of the galaxy 2 was probably
one of the most
exciting jobs i've ever worked on these
are some nice looking shots right all
indoor wow i believe it they feel like
they built the trees they built all of
it
oh that's a spider oh we popped it they
actually like made gummy spiders that
was gummies yeah they were
gummies here we go there's me well
that's you front and center yep i mean
this is in like all the trailers yeah i
got a trailer shot man
doesn't look anything like you
yo rockage is home alones us
oh man so he took it he went oh that was
a faceplant yeah he had the straight
faceplate they bury a pad in there or do
they yeah all right this is why this was
the most fun i've ever had on the set
shout out to tom harper the stunt
coordinator he linked up with set deck
and
made the ground foam
so the ground is super soft and then
they put the overlay of the grass then
when we were setting up for the drops
they would have like maybe three or four
guys on the button so we were literally
at the mercy of them communicating with
each other in certain places being and
go
and go
and we were getting blasted up and then
dropped down onto the soft pad would
they decelerate you a little bit on your
way down no
no i just pull you up twenty feet
up and drop you yeah wow so much fun
because that's that's how soft the
ground was oh so it's a huge cool
example of all sides and all teams
working together to build such a cool
fun sequence like this that's awesome
killzone alleyway fight
yeah sp i love this fight what does bl
stand for again super powerful
legs
would jin gets his ass whooped in this i
heard they actually improved a lot of
these fights yes and he gets his ass
whooped
now we're improving is that the improv
yeah this is where they're just swinging
at each other
yeah how many like
bump knuckles do you think happened in
this fight scene for wu probably like
every take he got cracked
oh
who did it first what the soldier knows
oh done
done done and for how chaotic this is
like i love that you can still see the
moment
haven't gone
this cranked a bit it's cranked a bit
but donnie is definitely moving at a
speed that i think woo was having a hard
time keeping up with there's a lot of
bts footage of them going at it back and
forth
and
donnie just being way too fast when they
start improving why not just choreograph
some cool stuff why why just do i think
there were moments in in the fight where
now we want to just have like filler
barrage so we can get shots of them
really feeling like oh i might get hit
or oh something's coming i have to react
to this quickly it's like musicians you
jam you know this did all these
movements they really not choreographed
so you get those pieces of magic that
you wouldn't get if you just had
choreography got you
samo versus donnie i love this fight
scene i know me too until
something
[Music]
go
this is where it happens
this killed it for me physics 100 right
here samuel hung how does he do it
from the momentum of a cartwheel
i love this whole part like it's messy
it's grappling it feels like fighting
yeah that's always been a thing that
people are scared of they don't want to
keep the actor on the ground
they they consider it to be sticky what
does that mean when they're on the
ground they want their actor their hero
to get up as fast as possible
the idea is that they feel that it's
boring and it's mainly because they they
can't capture it the same way they feel
they can capture stand up fight but now
with us getting knowledge from like the
ufc watching ufc fights the general
public is able to look at the ground
game now and be like oh he's going for
something or know that there's work
happening which is why john wick is so
fun to see because you get to see the
grappling aspect and honestly that's a
lot easier to teach your actor than it
is to get them to properly throw a punch
or a kick
so speaking of grappling yeah let's see
that flashpoint fight scene yeah we have
to we also had a lot of requests to see
his flashpoint in pisces you guys have
other stunts fight scenes things like
that that you'd like to see us talk
about on this channel please leave
requests down in the comments below we
read them all it's great feedback it's
great inspiration and please consider
subscribing
this is a sick fight scene yes it is so
intense it's still sweaty
it's ground fighting i love this
grappling it's like okay this is real
jiu jitsu that's what you really should
do yep get home again triangle choke i
know how to get out of this one like
this brute strike
[Music]
oh god back of my head
a little goofy towards the end i don't
know what happened we call it donnie
yeah he always has at least like one or
two things in this fight so you're like
wait a second
oh man
oh my god yo they'll wind up
i heard i heard that donnie would like
get a stuntman and be like hey man i'm
gonna give you an extra 800 bucks i'm
gonna knock you out real quick what wow
are you serious yeah and you'll take it
in china because like another thing
about chinese summon that's different
from us is that they don't get paid
unless they get on camera really they
can be there all day and not shoot
that's such and they'll get paid
that fight scene felt so crisp right
like just crispy but it's still chaotic
no it's very chaotic it definitely
stands out as one of the best fights of
our generation so how are these guys
pulling off a fight scene that's 10
minutes long and like doing these hits
over and over and over time drunken
master ii the final fight two months two
months they spent two months to shoot
that the next day after doing that stunt
we're freaking sore so your performance
isn't going to be as good as you would
want it to be if you're fresh so why not
give your guys that time to recover and
then go at it again in order for the
quality you have to really spend the
time you know so when you're shooting a
fight scene there's a couple ways you
can do it you can shoot in sequence
where you're just going to shoot this
one moment with your one angle that
you're going to use and then you're done
and you shoot the next moment with the
angle you're going to use and you're
done yep or you can shoot like a
dialogue scene where you shoot coverage
we shoot the entire fight from one angle
and you shoot the entire fight from the
next angle which way is the best way to
approach fight scene i think in a
sequence it helps having a previz
because the previous kind of gives you
an idea of the flow and where everything
is going to be and where's the best
place to see everything that's going to
happen where are your moments we
designed these moments and that's what
stands out to us the guy going through
the wall kicking through the table that
stuff is built and then you're like all
right now let's choreograph in between
those let's get to those points let's
get from a to b and then you're shooting
to an edit rather than just shooting
coverage coverage profile and then just
handing it to the editor and the
editor's like i wasn't there on the day
i don't know what exactly you guys are
looking for and now you have a fight
like the boys
all right so this is the boys this is
what i want y'all to see
[Music]
what is going on it's too cutty it's too
cutty and it's not in order this is for
real this is not fast forward no this is
at speed wait was there one frame of
nothing you're right that's just one
frame it just snaps out for one frame
why did you do that look at the leg the
freaking stork leg wait what what it was
just for lifting her leg up for what
dude i love how the guy slid wait checks
out look where he ends up she kicks him
right and then look out look at the
velocity right he's right there
[Applause]
tv compared to film you're dealing with
time right and you're dealing with also
having your actors especially if they're
leads they spent the whole day shooting
all the stuff leading up to the fight
that they get to the fight and now they
only have 15 minutes to shoot something
and they're like all right let's just
let's just get let's just get it done so
you you get a rushed product it comes
from a show that is not scared of
showing violence yeah and then they go
to a fight scene like this where you
don't see anything yeah a lot of times
especially like when it comes to stuff
where there's like a lot of posts that
needs to go into something to make it
good which fight scenes usually are part
of that yep the producer sits down who's
like just overseeing the entire thing
like this fight doesn't have it doesn't
it doesn't do anything for me it's like
well it's not done yet and they're like
chop it up chop it up faster faster that
i love i absolutely love dude i
seriously want to do some sound design
for the scene it would have to be
something like this
so the reason this episode is any good
is thanks to yugi really yeah no i think
it's because of the clips are the clips
actually you're right because if there
were the clips that just be three guys
sitting on the couch that's true uh you
can follow gui on instagram dxdasilva
yep gee thank you so much it's been an
absolute pleasure
hey don't click away i got one more
thing to tell you we've just dropped one
of the biggest projects we've ever done
on our youtube channel corridor go check
it out it's called rush it's a five-part
series it's inspired by video games it's
everything we want to do packed into a
project we finally got the rights to it
to show it to you for free on the
internet so go check it out and enjoy
yourselves